E aí
[Música]
a usar roupas confortáveis salvou a
minha vida e pode salvar a sua também
que que você tava fazendo lá pelos seus
12 e 13 anos de idade e nem festas
fazendo amigos estudando eu também o que
eu não sabia que eu tava entrando nos
períodos mais assustadores da minha vida
que duraria anos eu tava começando a
minha história com o serviço alimentares
e insatisfação com meu próprio corpo
e naquela época eu tinha a mesma altura
que eu tenho hoje pesava 20 que usa
menos estava completamente convencida de
que eu era gorda e de que isso era um
problema e não só um problema o maior
dos problemas
Oi e essa não é uma fala sobre
gordofobia porque eu nunca tive que me
preocupar se eu conseguiria passar na
catraca de um ônibus ou se uma
cadeirinha arrebentar na hora que eu
sentasse nela
eu não sou a pessoa certa para falar
sobre como a sociedade não está
preparada para pessoas fora do padrão
essa é uma fala sobre a minha
experiência que a única que eu tenho
como compartilhar sobre como a moda pode
interferir no processo de aceitação o
nosso corpo e quais as cores que a gente
tem nesse caminho
e nos anos em que em frente à anorexia
bulimia e de uma fé corporal eu tinha um
vício eu comprava roupas menores do que
eu usava elas como motivação para
aprender cada vez mais peso quem aqui
nunca teve aquela calça para quando
emagrecer era isso e assim eu entrei um
ciclo de competição comigo mesmo onde eu
queria emagrecer cada vez mais e nunca
era suficiente
e essa é a realidade de milhares de
meninas pelo mundo inteiro um estudo da
Associação Nacional da anorexia nervosa
e desordens associadas mostra que nove
porcento da população mundial sofre com
serviços alimentares Na época eu não
pude contar com o apoio psicológico a
minha família não entende o que tava
passando minhas amigas nem percebiam que
que tava acontecendo
e eu me envia a cada vez mais sozinha
isolada e eu lembro de um momento em que
eu percebi que eu tinha dois caminhos ou
morrer ou me aceitar foi quando eu li um
livro na escola Alice no espelho que
falava de uma menina que tinha
distúrbios alimentares anorexia bulimia
e do material corporal igual eu e eu me
reconheci em assolutamente tudo que ela
Fazia tudo que ela falava tudo que ela
pensava e no final do livro Ela
conseguiu escapar E aí eu decidi que eu
ia escapar também bem lentamente eu
comecei a desapegar da ideia de quem eu
queria ser
enxergar e acolher quem eu realmente era
E aí eu decidi que eu ia me desapegar
das roupas que eu comprei pegando
serviço aí também
Oi e aí eu lembro que eu sentada na
beira da minha cama encarando meu
armário olhando aquelas calças que
estava pronta para me desapegar e Surgiu
uma pergunta bem dentro de mim
naquela época não tinha ideia que essa
pergunta ia sair como um guia aqui no
mouse até hoje
é porque você tem que se adaptar suas
roupas e foi aí que eu comecei a abrir
espaço no meu armário e na minha vida
para o que eu chamo de roupas adaptáveis
e o que são roupas adaptáveis ou melhor
como descobrir se uma roupa é adaptável
se você emagreceu engordar alguns quilos
essa roupa vai parar de servir
quando você tiver inchado por exemplo na
TPM ela vai te apertar essa roupa
permite que você se movimente livremente
Oi e eu tenho quase certeza que na sua
cabeça tá vindo aquele conjunto de
moletom velho furado que você deixa no
armário ou então aqui ele pediu aqui
você usa quase todo dia acertei
é porque as roupas que a gente usa para
sair são tão diferentes das roupas que a
gente usa para ficar em casa e se a
gente tivesse peças que fossem bonitas e
estilosas que realmente refletissem
Nossa personalidade mas que não desce
vontade de arrancar na hora que a gente
chega em casa você consegue imaginar
aqui falando com vocês enquanto dois
pinos de uns 10 cm não impressionam com
muita força por exemplo no quadril
encontro mantenha a compostura e me
expresso claramente
impossível mas a gente vai para o
trabalho e é faz apresentações com peso
inteiro do nosso corpo suportado em um
salto agulha de 10cm e um sapato que
aperta que machuca que chega às vezes a
cortar o nosso pé e isso nem é uma
questão ou então se eu tivesse aqui
andando por aqui com uma fita amarrada
desde o meu quadril até o meu joelho que
me permitisse da passinhos mais ou menos
assim enquanto eu me concentro no que eu
preciso falar com você e chega a ser
ridículo mas a gente já faz isso quando
a gente escolhe por exemplo colocar uma
saia lápis justa com uma malha de tecido
que não estica não expande quando nosso
corpo tá sentindo algum desconforto ou
tem algum movimento limitado parte da
nossa atenção se volta para esse
incômodo é tipo quando a gente está com
tanto calor que a gente não consegue nem
se comunicar direito que na nossa cabeça
tá passando no meu Deus que calor
preciso me refrescar tô suando ou como
quando a gente quebra um osso foi coloca
um gesso que esquenta machuca e incomoda
e a única coisa que a gente consegue
pensar é no dia que a gente vai poder
tirar esse maldito desse gesso é o mesmo
processo quando a gente escolhe uma saia
por exemplo que fica subindo e a gente
tem que ficar ajeitando para baixo de 5
em 5 minutos ou um sapato que machuca
tanto que de cada cinco passa você tem
que dar uma descansada porque você não
consegue nem caminhar
e o nosso corpo tá inteiro conectado
literalmente entra nossa pele os
músculos tem uma camada que se chama
fáscia é como uma teia que envolve a
gente por completo órgãos e tudo então
se o seu dedinho do pé tá desconfortável
a sua orelha sabe o seu estômago sabe o
seu corpo sabe a sua mente sabe mas por
outro lado quando você tá confortável
ensino o seu corpo não é obstáculo ele é
uma ferramenta ele te ajuda a se
expressar melhor raciocinar melhor você
consegue dedicar toda sua atenção as
suas ideias
para que o interior esteja confortável o
exterior precisa estar confortável E
para isso você pode começar a
priorizando roupas confortáveis por
exemplo que se adaptam ao seu corpo
roupas que tem malhas que este cão por
exemplo elástico na cintura modelagens
mais largas E no caso de modelagens mais
justas escolher um tecido mais maleável
o fermento a pensar se depois do almoço
você vai ter vontade de tirar aquela
peça Se você não conseguir se sentar
confortavelmente
provavelmente Essa peça não é adaptável
como eu tenho Mania de levar todas as
minhas reflexões e descobertas pelas
redes sociais eu trouxe essa discussão
próxima seguidores de alguns anos se
vocês podem imaginar que eu recebo todo
tipo de relato principalmente de
mulheres que vão percebendo os
perrengues se passaram sem nenhum
reparar se já receber uma mensagem mais
ou menos assim Lela hoje eu usei uma
Calcinha apertada e só conseguia pensar
em você a e na hora eu fiquei meu jeito
que é isso E aí depois eu entendi o que
ela quis dizer aquela mulher de manhã
você ainda muita atenção escolher uma
Calcinha apertada para vestir que
acontece aqui naquele dia ela tem uma
apresentação muito importante no
trabalho e a calcinha tava tão apertada
que ela não conseguia nem que se
concentrar no que ela tinha para falar
apresentação acabou sendo um desastre EA
única coisa que ela conseguia pensar é
bem que ela avisou um bom jeito de
comprar roupas desconfortáveis é
procurar por exemplo naquelas marcas em
que a grade de tamanhos vai até o G ou
então que o GG Veste uma pessoa como eu
que pesa 60 quilos mais se você estiver
procurando por uma roupa confortável que
provavelmente vai respeitar o seu corpo
ciumenta procurarem marcas que têm grade
de tamanhos e modelagens pensadas para
pessoas reais com tamanhos reais
coerentes com a vida real
é coincidente mente em geral quem está
por trás dessas marcas são mulheres
também vários perguntar essa roupa é tão
linda que usar ela para sair mas tão
gostosa que eu escolherei ela para ficar
em casa uma roupa adaptável não se
adaptar o seu corpo mas a situações da
sua vida também
as flores da peças atemporais que não
são frutos de tendências ou modismos é
um ótimo jeito de você se auto-conhecer
e construir um estilo que faz sentido
para você para sua vida e para seu corpo
não sei se você sabe mas em geral as
tendências são pensadas por e para
pessoas magras e elas são projetadas
para ficarem cafonas Depois de alguns
meses a famosa obsolescencia programada
que a gente já conhece que tá ficando
cada vez mais rápido que você redes
sociais à moda ao longo dos anos mudam
muito mas tem algo que nunca muda se a
gente bobear se a gente não ficar atenta
a gente acaba caindo na armadilha de
desejar uma hora que quer que a gente
seja cada vez menor mas em defesa mais
frágil mas desconfortável
e afinal se você tiver em uma situação
de perigo você vai conseguir se defender
ou escapar com vestido tubinho em um
salto fino a moda é uma expressão da
cultura EA Nossa cultura entre muitas
outras coisas é sim patriarcal uma
cultura que não quer que a gente seja
dona das nossas próprias escolhas e nem
que a gente enxergue que a gente tem
escolhas não é você que tem que se
adaptar suas roupas são as suas roupas
que precisam se adaptar a você
você leva no passado 12 anos soubesse de
tudo isso talvez ela não tivesse passado
por tantas coisas difíceis
a e é por isso que eu acredito que uma
mulher confortável e sim é uma revolução
obrigada a
E aí